wir wollen jetzt darüber sprechen mit
dem geologen klaus stöhr uns jetzt
zugeschaltet schön dass sie bei uns sind
es scheint als könnte man sich einfach
nicht darauf einigen einen sinnvollen
und auch machbaren weg zu finden die
impfpflicht umzusetzen was wir ihr
vorschlag
erst mal komplett die gesamte diskussion
so vor als wenn man irgendeine lösung
gefunden hat so mental und dann
überhaupt alle anderen alternativen
ausblendet warum zwei andere
perspektiven auch noch vergisst die
erste ist die auch vorzulegen welchen
effekt die impfpflicht haben könnte also
wie viel neue infektionen kann man
verhindern wie viel einweisung auf die
intensivstation diese todesfälle wie
kann man die hospitalisierung reduzieren
und das kann man sehr gut modellieren da
hat die bundesregierung sich
hervorgetan im letzten jahr auch wenn
die vorlagen
vorhersage nicht alle so gut waren aber
das könnte man modellieren und sagen wir
in 4000 menschen aus dieser altersgruppe
und dann verhindern wir so und so spielt
kann es bei einweisungen wir können die
schulen wieder öffnen und so weiter also
diese zahlen fehlen aber das 2 oft fehlt
es offensichtlich die zeitliche
dimension letztendlich muss ja also eine
impfpflicht egal welcher natur
allgemeine impfpflicht nur die über
60-jährigen oder nur die über
50-jährigen die muss ja dann auch
irgendwie durch die parlamente durch und
dann muss er sie auch umgesetzt werden
oder ist es vielleicht schon märz april
und dann sind die eigentlich winter
messen mit kroner schon fast besungen
dann kommt ja frühling also was will man
hier mit eigentlich erreichen und diese
diskussion für mich also was sind die
wirklichen wirkungen die man erreicht
wie ob es die effizienz nicht
vergleichen das mit den alternativen und
kriegen wir das zeitlich überhaupt noch
hin bevor der winter ja sie stellen
genau die richtigen fragen was ist für
sie persönlich die antwort also würden
sie aktuell sagen mensch herr
bundeskanzler legen sie das zur seite
das bringt einfach nichts das macht ihn
eine menge ärger uns allen das
polarisiert wahnsinnig aber es bringt
halt nichts liegt zur seite die
impfpflicht ja ich stehe als experte an
der untersten schwelle der evidenz als
einzelperson ich würde mir eine gruppe
psychologen
kommunikationswissenschaft und sich auch
gesundheitsökonomen pomologen pädiatrie
aber auch ein paar virologen gleich und
bitten wir darum dabei und würde mir das
anschauen aber die kollateralschäden wie
gewirkt haben keines was man da auf gibt
dafür sozial was man anstelle der dem
die gesellschaft darauf damit so einer
maßnahme und dann den ball wie hoch
effizientes und dann würde man abwägen
wie vor nach der sich anschauen und dann
zu einer guten lösung kommen emotional
mit ohne alle daten zu haben aber einige
schon würde ich offen dass man jetzt die
situation mit omikron als exit strategie
aussieht von der bundesregierung man
kann das gesichter waren und kann er
sagen ja wie die australier die haben
gesagt das geld angekommen jetzt können
wir unsere strategie nicht mehr halten
jetzt sollte man vielleicht omikron
wählen in deutschland sagen wir lasst
uns noch mal die diskussion über die
impfpflicht neu auflegen lassen sie an
die alternativen anschauen was können
wir erreichen zeitlich was kostet uns
das an sozialen kolateralschäden was
gewinnen wir gesundheitliche
wirtschaftlichen aufwendungen bedeutet
dass und dann kann man das noch mal neu
evaluieren und dann vielleicht geht man
dann so pragmatisch an die tschechen wir
haben gesagt die über 50 oder
rechtlichen dass wir die machen wir
endlich da die krankheit platz beim
größten da gibt's auch in deutschland
noch drei millionen die nicht geimpft
das sind ja diejenigen die am
schlimmsten erkranken können die die
größte krankheit gleich noch aushalten
müssen und die
intensivstation man kann häuser auch am
meisten sicherlich dann herausfordern
würden das sind alles alternativen die
man hat zur allgemeinen endlich oder in
fliegt alle erwachsenen aus einer
perspektive glaube ich nicht ohne alle
zahlen und auch alle anderen fachgebiete
evaluiert zu haben dass man impfung
verpflichten für jugendliche machen
sollte um tatsächlich die probleme vor
denen deutschland jetzt steht die
pandemien lösen zu können
taster vielen herzlichen dank ihnen für
die einschätzungen es ist eine
schwierige debatte bei der sich die
politik ganz und gar nicht einig ist wie
man es umsetzt ob man es umsetzt und
wann man es umsetzt danke ihnen für ihre
einschätzungen schönen tag